so
first wives go to the Oscars oh yeah
tonight in our usual take no prisoners
style we are going to recap the nominees
for Best Original Song all of which you
heard render tonight in full throated
ferociously committed performances miss
hong a former Oscar winner herself will
kindly recite thank you from up close
and personal because you love me music
and lyric by Diane Warren
from one fine day for the first time
music and lyric by James Newton Howard
Judd J Friedman and Alan Dennis rich
from the mirror has two faces I finally
found someone I love that music and
lyric by Barbra Streisand
Marvin had said twice and Claude I've
known over 25 years Barbra Streisand
Marvin Hamlisch Bryan Adams and Robert
Mutt Lange I think I know much no
inanimate okay and now Miss Keaton who
is herself a nominee tonight yeah I
voted for you die
but you do already have one so will be
the end of the world you don't get one
no okay alright and alright from that
thing you do that thing you do music and
lyrics by Adam Schlesinger and from
Evita you must love me music by Andrew
Lloyd Webber and lyric by Tim Rice okay
so the Oscar goes to
okay the Oscar goes to Andrew Lloyd
Webber and Tim Rice
well thank heavens there wasn't a song
in the English Patient is all I can say
we must say thanks to madonna for coming
tonight and seeing the song so
beautifully and to alan parker for this
wonderful movie and as ever I agree with
everything andrew says and and I'd like
also to thank Robert Stigwood and David
land and everybody who helped on what we
think is a jolly good film thank you
thank you
there they go the yentas of Eastwick
what do you think guys good
when do we feed them never hi